你有看過完全免費無限制生成
還不用登錄的AI圖片網站嗎
產圖超快
品質好
還一次可以試這樣
今天我們就來實測給大家看
嗨我是阿湯
最近我發現一個很好的網站
叫做Lafail AI
打開就可以用不用登錄
無限次數完全免費
不管你是想要生成角色
插畫風格圖
甚至用來做LINE貼圖
還可以一次生成四層次的內容
你是不是也心動了呢
往下就帶大家來實際操作看看
Let's go
今天我們要來測試就是這個
Lafair AI
這個AI生成圖片的工具
我覺得算是非常的強大
畢竟它是目前全世界第一個
可以無限而且免費
也不用登錄的AI圖片產生器
你可以無限制
而且是蠻快速的生成
雖然你來看一下它的定價
他是講說呢至少每個月是Premium這個方案呢
才可以無限圖片生成以及有5倍速度的生成
而且沒有廣告沒有附水印
但事實上呢免費的使用呢不需要登錄的情況下
也是無限圖片生成
速度呢我不知道他5倍速度到底有多快
但是免費的使用的速度已經很快
一樣呢沒有廣告沒有附水印
免費跟每個月10塊的差異只差別在於快速生成這件事情
如果在網上呢就是差別在於畫質的部分
那這邊呢我們就直接不要登錄
然後我們就直接快速來生成來給大家看看
這邊呢它有一個小小的提示
就請大家呢盡量用英文來輸入這個prompt
這個呢就可以獲得比較好的效果
我自己試一下呢
確實用中文的效果跟英文的效果
即便是一模一樣的這個prompt呢
英文的效果產生出來也會比較好一點
那我們往下來看一下
這些呢是他們生成過的這些圖片
如果呢你不知道生成什麼來測試的話
你也可以試一下他們的prompt
比如說我點擊這張圖片
這邊就會有他使用的這個prompt
我們就可以來生成一次看看
好這邊呢我先不要加速
大家可以看一下這個到底要等多久
他預計是寫20秒
然後每次圖片都有一次生成4張如果想要讓速度快5倍的話呢就是選擇它的Premium一個月是10塊美金你可以看剛剛第一張圖大約就是10幾秒就生成出來了
好我們這4張都生成出來
大約30秒到1分鐘之內就搞定了
其實真的是蠻快的
那品質的部分大家可以看到
它生成這個樣式跟品質其實真的蠻好的
唯一差別的免費版呢
它的畫質只有512x512
所以呢是比較低一點點
雖然小小可惜但它就是免費你可以一直生成
那這邊有一個優化功能
點了之後呢它會針對圖片稍微去進行優化
但主要我覺得是把一些比較稍微模糊的部分呢
稍微加強一點有沒有你會覺得變銳利了一點
這是原始的稍微糊一點
然後這一張有再更清楚一點
所以呢當你弄完之後呢
你想要選擇哪一張圖片呢
你再去點擊然後選擇優化
可以讓這個畫質更好一點點
那這個圖片AI生成工具還可以生成什麼呢
比如說像我們之前很流行的這種公仔生成
我貼上一段英文的prompt
然後我們來生成一個貓咪
它是我之前中文的指令
翻譯過來大概就是
生成一隻Q版銀白太空服的貓咪模型
頭戴透明太空頭盔漂浮在火星岩地上
旁邊有迷你火箭以及行星模型
角色站在盒外
盒子是深藍銀星宇宙風格
上面會印有Cat Explorers的Logo
生成速度一樣蠻快的
那有些呢是生成的我覺得確實還不錯
像這張其實還不錯
唯一差別就是沒有張在盒外
這一張呢的貓咪呢
有點像是倉鼠了
然後像這個呢都有一個基本的品質
但是文字的生成上呢也是死毫死壞的
當然我覺得他的整體品質
沒有像Chall GVT那麼的穩定
不過他的生成速度真的是非常的快
而且一次會有四張
大致上都還會有一張你是可以使用的
接下來我也試了一下呢
就是生成公仔零件零售的那種排列圖示
你可以看一下目前生成的三張裡面
像這一張就還不錯
就有那種感覺了吧
就除了這個字沒有生成的很好以外
基本上公仔跟這個零件排列我覺得都做得還不錯
你看像第四張也做得還不錯
往下我們再繼續來測試
這邊中文我們也來試給大家看一下
我隨便複製了一段網路上的這個prompt也是關於公仔的我們用這樣的方式來生成給大家看看如果是用中文的話你可以看到用中文生成的話有時候就直接跳脫
你的所有的意思
就是他不會照你的意思來生成
會覺得怪怪的
然後我用了相同意思的英文的prompt
然後你看他立刻就生成出來了
所以建議大家如果你要用這個網站來生成的話
用英文的prompt會比較精準一點
中文有時候會生成的OK
有時候真的不行
除了像這種公仔生成圖片之外呢
那我們也來試一下其他類型的圖片
我們來產生一下
比如說像我們前陣子都在做Nine的貼圖好了
他能不能一次做出比較多張的Nine貼圖呢
我這邊給出的指令呢
是3x3
然後是亞洲女性職場的這種貼圖
一共會有9張在裡面
那其實我自己稍微試過了一下
3x3或4x4算比較剛好一點
如果你一次產生比較多
比如說是6x4或是5x5以上的話呢
這個其實蠻亂的
那貼圖的部分呢
他有時候會產生的還不錯
有時候真的蠻奇怪的
比如像我們看一下第一張
其實姿勢跟動作上好像還可以
像比如說這種手指有沒有
他就產生的怪怪的
表情的眼睛怪怪的
然後這五官怪怪的
這裡眼睛也消失了
你可以看一下下一張
這張的品質呢
整體來說就還算不錯
你就不會覺得說哪裡怪怪的
就比如說像這個
只有缺一個手
我們可以再往下看
這個就是沒有加上手的部分
但是旁邊有一些比較雜訊的東西
看一下最後一個
也是有怪怪的有沒有
所以我會建議一次就是3x3 4x4
我覺得算是還不錯
但是缺點就是呢
他沒辦法延續角色
他只能在同一張裡面延續角色
如果你是想要做完這一張
再去做下一張的話
角色是不會延續的
因為你沒辦法丟圖片去給他模擬
因為就是你丟圖片讓他去模擬的話
他只能是類似相似
而不會像TrackGPD做成一樣的風格
一樣的五官
接下來我們來嘗試一下深層
比如像是繪本的這種風格
會是長什麼樣子
像我剛剛這個只是單純的叫他說
媽媽牽著小男孩
然後看著月亮的這種繪本的風格
這兩個其實風格差不多
然後我覺得產生的還算不錯
如果你想要有更細的這種描述呢你就是可以再增加進去不過有點小缺點就是像這個啊如果你文字太多的話是貼不上來的雖然這邊沒有寫限制字數是多少
但事實上呢
如果你這個 prompt 的內容太多呢
它是沒辦法直接貼上來的
所以呢
你在請 chatgpd 產生 prompt 的時候呢
如果貼不上來的話呢
你就請 chatgpd 幫你稍微精簡一下
然後就可以貼上來
好最後呢
我們就再產生一個就好
那我們來試一下比較真人的
那我們用中文來試看看
試試看真人亞洲女生啦啦隊造型
就比較簡化一點的指令
這樣的中文我之前的嘗試是可以的
那我們來試試看這次能不能成功
好原則上算是成功的啦
就是真人亞洲女生啦啦隊造型
只不過你可能想像的是像職棒的那種
超可愛超浮誇那種啦啦隊的女生造型
沒有他的比較中國感一點
或是比較一般的那種場上的
加油加油的啦啦隊
最後一張有比較夢幻的一種
這種小女孩的啦啦隊感
其實生成的品質基本都還不錯
就是看你的prompt要怎麼去下
會比較精準一點
如果你不知道怎麼去下的話呢
就是記得可以透過TrackGPT來協助你產生這些prompt
然後描述的更清楚一點
它產生的細節就會更多
然後這個產出的圖片呢
都是只有512x512
那除了優化之外呢
你也可以把圖片下來之後丟給TrackGPT
請TrackGPT幫你優化這個畫質
就是提升這個畫質
也是可以的
至少都可以放大蠻多的
當然放大之後不見得畫質一定會提升到多好
但絕對會比你512X512原始的畫質來得更好一點
大家也都可以去試試看喔
就像你看到了這個網站操作其實就很簡單
它不需要註冊也沒有限制次數
而且生成速度很快品質也很不錯
不管你是拿來做練習當素材
甚至做一組貼圖都沒有問題
那我自己現在有事沒事
我就開來生成幾張看看
真的蠻香的啦
如果呢你也在找一个
即开即用的这种
AI 生成图片的工具呢
这个呢我觉得蛮值得收藏的
今天我们就分享到这边啦
喜欢这支影片的话呢
记得按赞订阅开小铃铛
我们下次见啰
拜拜